what does this science critic say well
again it's in line with what we have to
say today and that's visualization
is physics about visualization
should a theory of physics be
visualizable
can you illustrate should you
be able must you
be able to illustrate a mechanism of
physics
well hopefully the answer is yes there i
mean if if physics deals with objects
and objects is that which has shape then
there should be no reason not to
illustrate that which has shaped all the
objects that are going to cause the
mechanism to happen
okay that's the rationale so let's see
what the science critic have to say give
me a second here
the issue to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
a theorist has no excuse not to
illustrate the mechanism he proposes for
invisible phenomena such as gravity or
magnetism
bill do you know how difficult it can be
sometimes to create visualizations i
don't think every scientist has the time
to go ahead and create a movie that
visualizes the things that they are
thinking of of course there are quite a
few diagrams so that might be something
that you'll have to settle for bill
imagination is subjective
not objective i'm sorry bill but you're
going to have to settle for diagrams
because scientists are under no
obligation to provide movies to you they
are not film producers they are
scientists
okay so far says you should not be able
to you don't have to produce mandatorily
right uh a film of your mechanism
well the reason they do not
make illustrations i mean if you go to
the art side the
the uh where most of the papers
scientific or so-called scientific
papers are
filed
you hardly will find any paper with any
drawing with any pictures with any
images
and the reason is
they're talking about abstractions or
like mr bourne said max born he said
physics has become more and more
abstract
and yeah the problem is that abstract is
the opposite of physical
so physics is physical and these people
are doing abstractions so they're not
physicists they're abstracts okay
and so yeah you should be able to
illustrate a uh mechanism a theory
the causes right uh in physics a theory
of physics you should be able to
illustrate because that's what a theory
of physics is it's a mechanism you want
to understand how gravity works you had
better be able to illustrate the
mechanism
and he says look they don't have time
they're not film producers no that's not
the reason the reason is they have no
idea what the invisible intangible
objects
are out there that are performing all
these magic tricks that mother nature
does every day okay and again i'm going
to put the same ones up here here you
see them ah why not yes give me a second
here
these are the you know big bang what are
you gonna put for a zero dimensional
singularity be it a black hole or a big
bang okay what are you gonna put a zero
dimensional object what are you gonna
put for a dark matter you can't see it
or touch it
have a dark energy same thing
particle at two places at once what are
you gonna illustrate the rabbit at two
places at once i mean you're gonna
illustrate it but
what sense does that mean how are you
gonna tell someone look that's the same
rabbit at two places at once you know
what sense does that make how about an
excited field where are you gonna put a
bunch of numbers that vibrate weight
pack it what are you going to illustrate
that's why they don't illustrate because
they cannot all their concepts not one
of them is an object not one can be used
in physics
the atom you can't illustrate it because
again if you illustrate what you see
there you're going to have to explain
why that electron doesn't fly away
and what time you know what the hell is
that you know the work minutes warp
seconds is that what makes gps work
so again it's the the the reason they
have not been able to illustrate and the
reason they don't illustrate is because
that would be the physical
interpretation of whatever equation
they've got out there
and they say no no
mathematical physics which they call
physics is just equations
how about the the physical
interpretation we want to know how
gravity works how magnetism works you
say oh that's philosophy we don't do
that that's not physics that's not
physics according to the 17th century
so-called scientific revolution version
of the scientific method not according
to science genuine science which is
explain to me why this pencil
you know falls to the earth explain to
me what causes this magnet to be
attracted to the other we need an
explanation that's what they don't have
okay it's all irrational explanations
because they are putting concepts in
lieu of objects to try to explain and
others give you a physical
interpretation when it's an abstraction
explanation abstract explanation not in
physical explanation it's got nothing to
do with physics